Gauge rulers or gauge scales are not
machine-specific, they are
stitch and row specific.
In a recent Knitclub meeting,
UA knitter mentioned that she had gauge
rulers, but she didn't know
what machine they were for.
And this just didn't ring true to me,
so we decided to investigate.
Now, I've removed the color from these
images so we can examine
the rulers themselves.
We've marked 20 stitches and 30
stitches on this swatch.
Notice that the bottom ruler has
the number 30 printed right on it
in a circle so we can cheat here and we
know that this ruler is gauged for 30
stitches, but the top ruler doesn't
tell us how many stitches to measure.
Now, remember, we read the gauge rulers
in this direction,
so measuring 30 stitches with the bottom
ruler, we get 15.
Now that translates to 15 stitches
to four inches or 10 centimeters.
If we read the top ruler at 20
stitches, it also measures 15.
If we use a regular old ruler,
30 stitches measures, eight inches.
And if we do the math,
we also get 15 stitches to four
inches or 10 centimeters.
So all three scales,
no matter what color they are,
no matter what you call them, are
measuring the same gauge for my swatch.
The takeaway from this experiment is
that no matter what color the rulers
are, the top ruler is gauged for 20
stitches and the bottom ruler
is gauged for 30 stitches.
Now, here's another example,
using three different rulers.
Doesn't matter what machine
was used to knit the sample.
Again, notice that two of the three rulers
don't have any kind of indication about
what gauge to you they're
using or what to measure.
The swatch is marked at 40 stitches,
20 stitches and 30 stitches.
Now these are common gauges
for these gauge rulers.
Using the bottom ruler,
40 stitches, measures out at approximately
27 stitches to four
inches or 10 centimeters.
The middle ruler measuring against 20
stitches also measures 27 stitches to four
inches or 10 centimeters.
And the top ruler at 30
stitches measures the same.
And using a regular old ruler,
40 stitches measures
approximately eight inches.
Doing the math,
this confirms that the gauge
of the swatch, no matter what ruler we
use, is twenty seven stitches
to four inches or 10 centimeters.
So does this convince you that these
rulers are not machine-specific?
They are stitches and rows specific.
Also, have you noticed that other than
the markers on my rulers,
my little cheat sheets,
I haven't mentioned the words
standard, mid or bulky.
I don't know what machine
these swatches were knit with.
And it really doesn't matter.
What matters is the number of stitches
and rows that are measured.
If you have a white or purple or
a tangerine color ruler,
just confirm how it's gauged.
Is it gauged at 20,
30, 40 or maybe even some other stitch
count. Once you establish what
that is, mark the ruler.
So there's no guesswork and you can
use this ruler again and again.
One last thing.
In studying my three gauge rulers,
I noticed that the largest number
on the stitch side of the rulers is twice
the stitch count that
the ruler is gauged to.
In other words, the yellow ruler is a 30
stitch gauge and the largest
number on that scale is 60.
On the 20 stitch gauge ruler,
its largest number is 40.
On the 40 stitch gauge ruler, the largest
number on the stitch scale is 80.
Now, this isn't true on the
row side of the scales.
Hopefully, this will help you identify any
mystery rulers that you have and also
convince you that the gauge
rulers are not machines specific.